president Trump is being widely
criticized for suggesting that 99% of
coronavirus cases are totally harmless
that claim is not true in the mayor of
Austin Texas where cases are surging
called the remark dangerous while the
read reports from the White House now we
have tested almost 40 million people by
so doing we show cases 99 percent of
which are totally harmless President
Trump made that unsubstantiated claim on
July 4th but even his own FDA
Commissioner dr. Stephen Hahn struggled
to support it is the president wrong so
I'm not gonna get into who's right and
who's wrong what I'm gonna say Dan is
what I've said before which is that it's
a serious problem that we have
Houston's Mayor Sylvester Turner is
battling a record spike in infections he
refuted the president's statement the
number of people who are getting sick
and going to the hospitals has
exponentially increased the number of
people in our ICU beds has exponentially
increased the mayor of Miami Dade County
also insisted the president was wrong if
it were harmless I wouldn't be taking
the steps that we're taking here in
miami-dade the president also
contradicted his own public health
experts on the timeline for a vaccine
and will likely have a therapeutic and
or vaccine solution long before the end
of the year I can't predict when a
vaccine will be available former Trump
homeland security adviser Thomas Bossert
issued this warning we have to start at
the basics and level with people
suggesting that it's not dangerous
isn't itself a dangerous message the
Trump campaign has announced an outdoor
rally this Saturday at the airport in
Portsmouth New Hampshire but a recent
campaign rally resulted in dozens of
Secret Service agents and campaign
staffers having to quarantine after
several tested positive but in
Portsmouth the campaign says attendees
will be provided with masks and
encouraged to wear them Gayle
all right Thank You Paula we can't
stress that enough